so so maybe just before you know and
just before uh i continue i just want to
kind of clarify this talk that this
point that uh in discussion with
natalie's we wanted to make sure that
this point that
what the different people care about
different regimes so so to a first
approximation basically
if you're a statistical physicist
then you uh only care
about uh you care about this point but
you don't care about what happens be
beyond it because you only care you your
basic
case is uh you know random problems uh
maybe you started talking about you know
inference
but but you really care about
random system like standard statistical
system uh
systems that and you care when when
they're no longer solution there is no
landscape anymore
from this point on all of them look the
same so to a first approximation if
you're a statistical physicist
you only care about this part
now if you
if you you know theoretical machine
learning
you know generally machine learning or
that is theoretical and you
interested in the inference
then this part
generally doesn't interest you because
this red part which is what the
statistical physicists care most about
this is just noise
you really care about things
on the on the right side so you really
care about the this line when do things
become say computationally easy
so so to some extent uh you know one
part really cares about this regime one
part who cares about this regime but the
interesting thing
is that you can still use the same type
of algorithm so for example you could
use gradient descent
or local algorithms you can use it
to try to do inference
and and recover the signal
but you can also do use it even if there
is no signal you can only use it here to
try to recover you know to minimize the
ground state
so it's the same algorithm
but in some sense you're trying to do
something very very different here
you're trying to recover the ground
state
or you know a random ground state maybe
there are many of them but from the
point of view of someone trying to do
inference this is just recovering the
noise it's something since not
interesting and you could not recover
the signal because there's simply more
noise than signal
but from the point of view of
statistical physicists that's really
still very interesting to try to find
the ground state
from the point of view of uh
you know if someone does the inference
you care here
about trying to recover the signal but
uh you know from the point of view of
statistical physics the problem has
become trivial long long ago so if you
think of for example of the
this problem p x or
then this line will generally be
roughly
n to the uh
delta is n to the
p over two minus one so for example for
a three x so this is basically you have
n to the 1.5 constraints this is way way
out there beyond the problem is no
longer satisfiable
and then
so so these are kind of the different
regimes but i really hope that
eventually we'll find a unified picture
that
gets both of them
because we do seem to use similar
algorithms
so i um but so i really hope that
eventually will get a unified picture
okay so now
i hope we'll start doing a little bit of
math at least
to
feed the appetites of those that
had enough of graphs and figures and and
philosophy
and
wants to get what they came here for
so uh right so we are looking at this
pxo problem
and we want to show
that's a pxo problem for a three and
above
or at least something like that like
let's say we'll focus on four maybe but
uh he is actually hard so we want to
look at hardness for local algorithms so
what is a local algorithm we are not
going to completely locally define it
but here is the general
idea of what is local or generalized
local algorithms even some algorithms
that are not exactly local kind of fall
under this uh
this general umbrella so we're looking
at an algorithm to try to solve the
search problem so an algorithm that
gives given j
and the goal is to find a minimizer for
j or at least something that's close as
as possible to a minimizer
and generally these type of local
algorithms have the following form they
start by initializing x0 to some value
that is independent of j maybe it's
random maybe it's zero something some
value that is independent of j
and then do a sequence of local
improvements
so for t equals one two three et cetera
we keep we we
xt is going to be xt minus one and we
make some local improvement what is the
local improvement we
we look at nabla
some function of
our instance j the previous state maybe
sometimes we also look at some even more
previous states or some other you know
maybe also the current
the current position
and we make this local update and the
idea is that uh for it to be a local
algorithm you can basically say any
algorithm you can kind of phrase in this
way but we
we want to restrict ourselves to somehow
simple local updates
and i'm not going to completely define
what is simple and local but generally
simple should be some kind of a simple
function maybe a low degree polynomial
or maybe you know some gradient or
something like that
of a
of the input you know the j and the the
prior state and sometimes you also look
you know say for example in mp you look
at some of some previous states as well
and
and in gradient descent for example you
have like a learning rate schedule so
you also you know it's some function
also the
current step that you're in
with some kind of a simple function
and local means that we're not going to
make big changes so generally xt is
close to xt minus one
so this is the general framework of
local algorithms
and typically in these local algorithms
i kind of presented it sequentially but
you can also perform these changes in
batching parallel you can take like a
bunch of
uh
you can kind of pre-compute this delta
in
a bunch of these deltas and make all of
these things uh in parallel
and generally the parallel depth of
these algorithms typically is just a
function of accuracy
so many of the local algorithms that we
look at like amp etc
generally they just keep like off and
memory
and and
and they can do off and updates in
parallel so they only need like off one
iterations where this off one depends on
whatever accuracy you want to achieve
but then this is the idea of local
algorithms where we'll see what property
we kind of use uh for local algorithms
but so there is a lot of
there there is a lot of work of showing
that uh the overlap gap property so this
this overlap distribution when it has a
gap which basically means it's
um
it's kind of in this clustering regime
then it's a barrier for local algorithms
and also for some other types of
algorithms
and and there is a lot of work probably
this is only
even a partial list
there are a number of people
in that are in the room and especially
uh you can see that the name gamonic
kind of appears uh quite a lot in this
uh overlapping
uh
overlapping property works and so i hope
that he will forgive me because i'm
probably going to butcher his work a
little bit i mean in terms of like
presenting a very simplified and cartoon
version
uh in a in a slide or two but i hope it
will give the general a
idea and you you feel free to connect to
correct me
a forgiveness that's great
so so let's remember what is this
overlap distribution so we have this
picture
and we have this overlap distribution
this is the distribution of the overlap
between two random and say minimizers so
think of p star as the uniform
distribution over minimizers
and
and we have this uh overlap distribution
let's yeah i should have really put this
with absolute value but it doesn't
really matter
so so in general in the
in the easy case the
in the easy case you kind of have the
the
there is no overlap gap there you kind
of have a
a general
and
you you have a general and
it's kind of an interval the support and
in fact
if
you know in high dimensions you expect
that two random things will be nearly
orthogonal so you basically have
in the full interval
and in the hard case you have some kind
of
an overlap gap you have some pair you
know a b
such that there is never a there does
not exist
x1 and x2 in the support
such that the
x1 x2 let's suppose there are unit
vectors just two
is in a b
so here is some intuition and the
intuition is based on the four spin
model i think by the way you new paper
is on the first pin model but probably
something similar should be true also
for three-spin
you're not a way to verify but
conjecture that is true right
yes so so the
so they looked at the paper they looked
at the
uh the case where it's a four-speed
model and the coefficients are in normal
and here is a cartoon of the proof
though so the this is a proof that local
algorithms
um when there is the overlap that
property local algorithms cannot uh
cannot find the the maximizer
and here is the cartoon of the proof and
of course i didn't completely define
local but you'll see what property of
local algorithms i need
so let's assume for the sake of
contradiction that there is some local
algorithm a such that if you give
a j as input it finds x star that is in
the support of this distribution
and so the support of the minimizers
and now let's define for uh say for t
which is between zero and one
let's define
the uh
jt to be
you know
the combination of
j prime and j double prime where j prime
and j double prime are two independent
tensors and this combination is chosen
so that you know its coefficient is
still a standard normal
so
j0
is just j prime
so j1 is j prime and j
0
is a j double
prime okay so now oops let me
so now let's draw the following thing so
uh if you run
say let's track the
this a gets as input j and outputs a
vector
so let's just say that when you give it
j zero
you get x of zero
so that's so define x of t as the vector
that is output by a on input jt
and
so x1 is a on j1 and x8
and x0 is a on
j0
and generally
for any t xt is
what a outputs on jt and a of course can
be a randomized algorithm but let's say
we fix the randomness we chose some
certain randomness and fixed it
now let's track the dot product and
again maybe i should have done this
thing but the absolute value but doesn't
matter so much
of
xt and x1
so
because this is um
obviously x1 and x1 have dot product one
so obviously
xt equals x1 so the dot product will be
one
and if you there's two kind of random
there are two random tensors then the
dot product of the output
for j and j j prime and j double prime
should be
basically they should be orthogonal so
this starts at zero and ends at one
and now the property that we use of
locality and the property that
grammatical and jagannath will prove
is that because it's local this is going
to be continuous so this is going to be
some curve that starts with zero and
ends with one
[Music]
so definitely at some point
it's going to cross it's going to cross
in this interval a
b
and now the
they prove in some sense i think
actually that's why they may be
conjecture but i don't know maybe it's
been proven already that
you have a very strong overlap gap
property which is not only that uh
not only the support of q
so that they basically this is true even
uh
even if you look at say you define this
um
x1 comes from some t and x
two comes from some t prime
uh from the so these come from pt and
this comes from if it is prime for any t
and t prime
and z1 so it's some kind of an extended
extension of this overlapped gap
distribution that even then you don't
find any dot any
curve that have the dot product in this
interval
and so once you do that you get a
contradiction right so you there it must
be some t star
so that
x t star and x one the the dot product
is in this forbidden interval which
contradicts the overlapping poverty
so that's basically the assumption and
the point where you use the fact that
a is local is in discontinuity that
basically as you vary the vector doesn't
go
if you slightly vary the coefficients of
j prime of j as you change t smoothly
then the vector is not suddenly going to
jump from one place to the other
is that like a fair
cartoon that you mentioned the mark uh
result
so mark proved it well there's a version
of it on the on the hyper cube versus
the
boolean cube and that there was some
something to be closed and captioning
not
so so available is this so this is a
katum but you can see how the overlapped
graph property implies a computational
hardness
yes
so basically
uh
for with high probability over uh j
prime and j double prime for every uh
pair t t1 and t2
there is not going to be a
say an approximate minimizer for j prime
an approximate minimum is a approximate
minimizer or j t prime and approximate
minimizer of j t double prime
that the dot product is in this
forbidden interval right
in fact t prime equal to t double prime
is the
is the bottleneck because once you
perturb the model
even a little bit the chances of having
two near optimal solutions with the
prescribed distance goes down so
when t is equal to
the prime that's that's the what you
really care about right the rest is
more or less straightforward right and
with d equals to t prime is exactly the
situation where statistical physicists
have studied to get the left and they
understand why the overlapping property
holds so in some sense the hard case is
the case that's also the most well
studied
so so this is basically shows uh
if you have overlap the problem should
be hard
and
now let's let's talk about why when you
you don't have overlap the problem
should be easy so in general there are
kind of two reasons why the pro you
should you might be without overlap
so one reason one scenario is this
scenario that i do before this is the
replica symmetric scenario where
essentially all your solutions are kind
of living in one big cluster or ball and
that's kind of intuitively easy
and then you have this overlap when you
have this
what you call one replica symmetry
breaking you it breaks into clusters so
in some sense instead of having like
this
the solutions don't really leave like in
they they live in this
you know
several
clusters but in general you could even
have these clusters
break themselves into subclusters and
subclusters now if you can kind of
continue this
uh
you continue this
like a number of times that goes to you
know goes to infinity with the size of
the system that's what's called full
replica symmetry breaking
so in full replicative breaking
the intuition is that the you have
clusters
and then you have subclusters and then
you have sub-sub-clusters and generally
every solution
it's eventually uh
you know if you had the say d choices
for the first class
these about them let's recall it i don't
know c choices for the first cluster i
know c1
see two choices for the second cluster
et cetera so a solution you can kind of
parameterize it by
you know which
which choice you made in the first case
uh i know i1 i2 i
i 3 et cetera and the depth of it is say
d so it's kind of like every solution is
every cluster is you can think of it as
a leaf of some tree
and different solutions i mean the every
every sub sub smaller cluster is
basically some leaf of these three
and in this case
uh you can think of x as basically uh
another way to think about it is that x
has this component so first by choosing
whether you know it's in which cluster
you kind of chose one of
several choices of what will be x1 this
x1 is basically the vector that's
contribution from the first cluster the
second cluster etc and up to
the d cluster
and if you have x and x prime
then the distance between them is
basically proportional
to
how in their distance in the tree
what's their nearest common ancestor
if the nearest common ancestor is you
know closed and they are nearby if it's
far far then they're further away and
when you have a metric that corresponds
to the distance on the tree it's called
an ultrametric
so this is in in a full replica symmetry
breaking this is kind of a situation
where the solution geometry doesn't look
like what i said before it's never one
ball
nor is it like
some disjoint clusters
and but the interesting thing is that if
you think about it in the full replica
symmetry breaking
the overlap
is actually uh continuous
because in some sense you can think of a
you know you can think of like you
basically are choosing the first digit
of the overlap and then the second you
know this is a you can think of it as
suppose all of the c's were the same
then in some sense the overlap is a
random number a fraction that expressed
in the c re basis
this chooses the first digit of this
overlap and then this chooses the second
digit so that would be like a uniform
and generally it doesn't have to be
uniform but it's going to be
continuous
because this because the depth goes to
infinity
so this is the case where there is no
overlap
so the intuition may be that if there is
no overlap the problem should be easy
and that's basically um
is believed to be the case and i think
there was like some more works that i
know of but let me mention that's just a
a few recent works that basically have
shown that
in some very interesting scenarios where
there is no overlap gap
then
there is actually a
polynomial time algorithm and in fact an
algorithm that is kind of local that's
basically
along the lines that we've seen before
so the type of algorithm that would be
ruled out when there is an overlap gap
so
these works
so basically uh
so buck did it for something called as
the mix
a
spherical uh p spin
wanted that now he did it for the
sharing tone
then you guys did it for more general
what's the family or how do you what do
you call this the whole family it's all
peace pins or
i think it's also mixed piece
it can be um
the general generalization the common
generalization of that which basically
took at all mixed
so you generalize it into you know you
you allow mixtures and you allow both
spherical and over the boolean cubes so
character patek is like p equals two
and over uh the cube
and this one's over the sphere
and they basically generalize it to all
of those the common unified
generalization
so what is the mix well the easiest
problem at least for me the easiest
thing to describe is zubac so i'm going
to focus on subug
on the result of the bug so the mixed
spherical p spin model
the idea is you have some mixture of
these uh
say tensors so you think of
j of x
is you have some coefficient gamma 2
times the dot product of j 2 and
x and z 2. so this is like just a matrix
and some you know x i j
x i x j and the corresponding
coefficient i j
and this is uh you know gamma three and
these three tensor you uh some i j k x i
times x and x k and you can continue
onwards
though um
for simplicity on the slides i'm only
going to look at the two and three
coefficients
and generally we'll look at the case
where we maximize or minimize over the
unit sphere where you know norm of x is
one and then
the um
the no the entries of the these tensors
are iid in in
standard normal with uh
normals with a variance one over n
just
normalization which makes life easier
so
let's define this
polynomial this univariate polynomial
new new of q
which is sum of gamma p squared
q to the p so basically
uh
gamma 2 squared q squared plus
gamma 3 squared q cubed plus
now you can do the math and see that say
um if you uh
if you fix x
and you vary you take j to be
a random
normal with these entries
then j of x will be uh
will be as a standard normal photo so
for every fixed x if the random s is
over j
this will be a normal with a
variance which is new one over n
okay and this is
you know just calculations
just because the sum of normals is a
normal and the variances add up
independent normals so it
sums up to this
and if you look at
[Music]
x and x prime
then the
expectation of over j of j of x time j
of x prime
is um
is near power applied to the dot product
divided by n and again this is just
you do the math and it comes out so
these are uh
the set and
the set j you know this random variable
g of x for all x in the sphere
it's like a gaussian process called one
gaussian random variables where this
kind of determines this parameter new
determines their correlations
now the theorem of subarg
this is what this is the theorem of
shows that
there is a
polynomial time algorithm
that with high probability over j
achieves this value so let's ignore for
every epsilon so let's ignore the
epsilon so basically output string
an output something that achieves this
value
which is the
minimum of this integral of square root
of the second derivative of new
so
let's the important thing about this
value is that there was a previous
theorem of chen and sen and the
physicists have known it actually way
before then
that
if you have the case where there is no
overlap
then this is actually this value is
actually the true minimum of the the
system this is the the ground state or
the this is the the minimum and the
minimum the two minimum so basically
so bugs theom says that in particular
whenever you don't have an overlap
then you can achieve the two minimum
when you have an overlap this algorithm
will get stuck at this value where the
two minimum will be even smaller but
then
but if you don't have an overlap then it
will achieve the two minimum
and now we're going to sketch the proof
so before we i mean because this this
expression at least to me looks a little
bit mysterious let's see why at least it
makes sense in the simplest case that we
can think of where the you know just uh
when there is only uh gamma two is one
and all of the rest are zero so it's
just a random matrix
yes
what what parameter are we making when
we ah great great question yes the
vector gamma
so the vector gamma determines the this
polynomial
uh this polynomial new
and
and and for different gammas
different gammas uh that
it would be um
depend it would depend and just say
intuitively
um if gamma if gamma 2 is 1 and the rest
of zeros this is just a matrix and there
is no overlap gap
if gamma 3 is 1 or if say gamma 2 is 0
and one of the others is 1
then this is like a pure p spin where
for p larger or equal to three and there
is an overlap gap
so intuitively the condition is
something like gamma two some sense
dominates the others so it can be shown
that say if gamma two equals 0 then
there will definitely be an overlapped
gap and in some sense there is
the condition of the problem being easy
is that in some sense the the
combination of the two parts somewhat
dominates the the others to some extent
and then
yes
that means
setting that you just described
something although i think like in in
this case i don't know if it's like full
replica i mean symmetry breaking because
this is just the eigenvalues so it's
like also it's either like replica
symmetric or full replica estimated
breaking
i'm not sure it's it's relatable with
that because you could fully replicate
battery braking i'm not mistaken
means that that the the overlap
distribution has continued partners
support but that might include the case
of overlap gap or nothing so it could be
interval versus not interval and that's
what determines whether there is a gap
non-full replica symmetric breaking
means that the supported discrete set of
points so yes i'm sorry sorry my
understanding
okay so so so
so yeah there might be some kind of i
don't know if there is an intermediate
situation where you have disjoint
clusters but then within within them you
have like full replica symmetry breaking
which maybe
would be a case where you have a gap the
problem is hard but i don't know what
they would call it so
so let's just say no overlap gap
easy overlap gap hard
and i guess like for reference
so maybe there's different scenarios if
i'm not sure if what they call exactly
frsb if uh
so
so i'm not completely sure whether
they're like some of those scenarios you
could have a frsb
weave a gap and if you do then
then then it will still be hard
and i guess that would be a situation
where you first break into these joint
clusters but when in each one of them
you have like this
ultrametric type of poverty
so okay so let's look at this the
simplest example where gamma
this is a question we know this the
problem is supposed to be easy right
when gamma
is just a vector one in the the
coordinate so gamma two equals one
and the rest of zero so
and then uh this um
this this polynomial is simply q squared
and it's the second derivative is simply
the two
so now this this uh
in this case j of x is simply you know
uh you apply externally you apply the
quadratic form to this matrix
uh to this matrix j and
it's easier for us to see to work with
symmetric matrices so because x i x j is
equal to x j x i it will be the same if
we take the average of j and j transpose
so this is the same as applying uh
the quadratic form of j plus j times
pose over two
now what is j and so let's just call
this matrix a
so if i is different from j then
basically we are looking at right each
coefficient here
right
each coefficient here is like n01
if you look at half
zero one then the variance is squared so
this will be
n zero uh four sorry one over n so that
will be one over four n and then you add
two of them then you'll get one over two
n
so for i different than j a i j is
distributed like normal with variance
one over two n
when uh
when i is equal to j
then this is the uh aii you're you're
looking at just two times and
two times the same normal so you get uh
so so now you get n zero one over n
okay this is uh right so
if x is distributed like n zero
uh
one over n
then
x
x plus x over 2 is just x
and
and if x and y are independent and 0 1
over n
then x plus y
equals 2 is distributed like m 0 1 over
2 n
ok so
once we do that
then
then we can see that a
is just a
1 over square root 2 times a prime
where a prime is distributed according
to the gaussian orthogonal ensemble so
if a
gaussian orthogonal assembly is just
basically when a prime i j for the id
front of j is like n 0
1 over n and a prime i i is n 0
2 over n and it's well known
that the
spectrum of the gaussian orthogonal
assembly can ranges between minus two
and plus two
so the smallest one in particular is
minus two
so the minimum eigenvalue of a
will be a one over square root two times
the minimum aggregate value of a of a
prime which will be minus square root 2.
and that's a good thing because uh
obviously the
minus the integral from 0 1 of square
root 2
is minus row 2. so this is what we
wanted
so at least we get
that uh
this algorithm it's the
the the least good way of finding maybe
the minimum eigenvector of a random
matrix but at least we get that we get
the right answer so uh so at least we
get some intuition why this expression
at least sometimes makes sense
okay
so now
and
let's discuss the algorithm
so when
the algorithm is is the following we
initialize x0 to be just the all zeros
vector
and then we do the following thing we
take
one over eta squared steps and eta will
be some parameters just will set to zero
to you know to get our accuracy
so think of it as a very small constant
and we'll take a ut is going to be a
unit vector
that is uh in the following
subspace
so okay so so now it's going to be the
following thing we take the hessian
of j at x t minus one
so
and we take the mini bottom egg in space
of that
and we intersect it with the
things that are orthogonal to u1 till ut
minus 1 all the vectors we had so far
and also the gradient
of j at x t minus 1.
now the bottom space of this session
generally if we are willing to fudge a
little bit and maybe not exactly the
bottom but some lose some epsilon
accuracy
then its dimension is going to be linear
so
and this is only a constant number of
vectors we can find the vector uh that
is in that subspace and also orthogonal
to you know this constant number of
remaining ones
okay so we find a vector that's
basically has
its correlation with the hessian is
roughly the minimum eigenvalue of this
uh
of this session and it's also a
how do you say hessian
so that i'm at least right 50 of the
time and
and
and so you will find a vector that its
correlation with the hessian is um
about its minimum eigenvalue and it's
also organized to all the vectors we
chose before plus also the gradient
okay
and kind of if it's a kind of a
randomized matrix
it should be the the spectrum should be
kind of continuous so you would uh
yeah so if you're willing to lose a
little bit of epsilon accuracy you
should have plenty of dimension to be
orthogonal to these vectors
and now we just uh
here we and now we just update we let x
t be x t minus one minus eta times
u t this vector
and we end up by outputting the final
vector that we get like so with t from
one till one over theta squared so with
it outputting x one over l squared which
is the same
as uh right minus the minus is actually
not going to change man but let's skip
it so it looks like gradient descent
and minus eta times t is the sum from t
equals 0 to 1 minus over a squared of ut
so this is the algorithm
now we just want to analyze it
and let's just make sure that we output
a vector of the right norm
so because all of these vectors are
orthogonal we chose it by design
then uh each one of them has norm
now eta
the they're all orthogonal so one over
eta squared
orthogonal vectors each of them is of no
eta they their sum has norm one
and this is actually
kind of important for us
that we are able to take one over at the
squared steps
just on intuition we we're able to take
one over at a squared steps and to get
the num1 vector even though each one of
them is of known eta
and that's to some extent why we are
able to use hessian rather than gradient
and still get something that makes sense
okay so now we want to analyze it so
using the taylor we know that if we add
like a small vector to
x
then
we get something like uh the
contribution is like the
you know the dot product of the gradient
and this and the the
the
you know the correlation the quadratic
form of applied to the hessian
uh
with a
half right this is just taylor
approximation
and
by design
we had our vector was orthogonal to the
gradient so the second so this part
is meaningless
so basically what we are going to win in
each step
we are going to win a half times
at a squared because the right u
transpose
we are going to use our vector u
in step t the vector u is going to be
eta times u t
so we are going to win a
winning sense in the sense of decreasing
the objective
half at a square times the minimum
eigenvalue of the hessian at this step
so
or maybe this is t minus 1 doesn't
really matter
30 minus 1 let's keep it t for
simplicity
so by kind of symmetry and concentration
these are all random things
so uh
the you know j is kind of spherically
symmetric so it really
what we expect to be the minimum
eigenvalue
really only will depend on the norm of x
t and not the particular vector because
the distribution on j is spherically
symmetric and we are only going to do
this to look at this minimum eigenvalue
for a constant number of steps so it's
all concentrates very well so we can
just
look at the minimum
so we can just look at the
what we expect to be the minimum
eigenvector eigenvalue
of the hessian of j evaluated at the
vector that is like say just
the norm of x t and z was everywhere
else so this is just we rotated
x t to some nice form
so the point is that the the minimum
eigenvalue really only depends
on the norm of xt doesn't depend on the
particular direction because j is
spherically symmetric and we expect
these things to be very very well
concentrated
that's good
again
commons questions are good so let's just
define this lambda
so just define uh
basically i'm going to define
lambda of
so so i'll just call it
this is lambda
lambda of the norm right so the norm of
x t is going to be eta times square t
so just define
lambda of uh
i don't know what to call it
lambda of
a
to be a lambda mean
of uh or the expectation if you want uh
or the mean of
the hessian at
i applied the vector alpha
a
and the rest is zeros
and i'll i'll just call this lambda of
square root q
where q is a
q is just at a square t
and the reason i use the
parameterization with q is because eta
squared t ranges from zero to one right
we recall this is basically the norm
squared
q is going to be the norm squared of uh
of the x this vector and it starts at
zero it stands at one and it's uh and it
increases uniformly
so
if we were to uh to think of eta as kind
of infinitesimal then
dq is at the squared
so
if we uh
so basically um
what we win we said is uh we win at each
step
half times eta squared times this lambda
of square root q so if we take f theta
to be infinitesimal what we win is
the
integral from zero to one of half times
lambda of squared q times dq
so now
basically what we need to prove is that
this lambda of
lambda mean
of this thing is uh
is equal
to
in expectation or with high probability
these things all concentrate to the two
times the square root of uh the second
derivative
of a new new one q
and now this is just calculations
so basically uh
you know what is the hessian
just open this up
you know you get this contribution from
the second
thing uh contribution from the third
thing etc
and now you just kind of add it up and i
think i'll just go because we're
starting to run out of time i'll just
kind of go quickly and you you just do
the math
and
and and it just you know
just basically is going to be
you just do the math it's going to be
some coefficients some
it's going to turn out that this session
is is just a random matrix that is some
coefficient times a random matrix that
comes from the goe and it the
coefficient is exactly what you need it
to be
this
so
the slides will be shared but this is
just math
okay so
how much time do i have
okay
so um
okay so that's good so so if you just so
so that was just basically what we have
seen now
is uh that we if we the solution
solution landscape or overlap gap kind
of characterizes uh
in this regime
in this regime
basically uh the the solution in
landscape kind of characterizes where
the problem
is supposed to be easy and hard when we
don't have an overlap
when we do when we don't have an overlap
gap we expect the problem to be easy
when it
it appears
and there might be some kind of
more uh
[Music]
in some in some cases maybe there is
some kind of in this dynamic regime
where you might have to define the
overlap wrap a little bit more
sensitively because
you have this exponential number of
clusters that not necessarily show up in
the in the overlap but but generally
speaking the solution landscape
it can characterize for us the
difference between uh easy and hard
so so in this region we kind of
understand things but here
there is no landscape so we need to
try to find different ways to understand
when things become easy or hard
and and one example to show the
difference between the two model is this
sharington chiropractic model
so in the sharing tonkyopatric model
let's say the x-axis
uh so what is the characteristic maybe i
should say that because i think yeah so
the shameful hypothetic model let's a j
you know j comes from the gaussian
orthogonal ensemble and we look at j of
x is just x transpose
j x
and
and generally maybe i should say yes so
generally let's say the x here is minus
alpha so this is basically the uh how
the minimum value so this this is
basically
want to try to look
at x transpose
so
is that mine
so we oops
let's stop
so and
so and so we look at the x and x
transpose a
here we looked at a x transpose j x
uh or minus x transpose j x and we're
trying to you know uh maximize minus x
transpose j x or minimize x transpose j
x
so the true er
over the hyper cube yes over the hype
team so the true maximum so so yes so
the true uh the true maximum of minor
the two
maximum of minus j excellent for the jx
is going to be this is the famous theory
famous result of parisi that later
confirmed by telegram something like
1.53
while in the uh by looking at the
maximum eigenvalue of this orthogonal x
and symbol as we can
as we can have shown you can show that
it's not larger than two
and this so and
so you definitely above two it's easy to
refute we can certify that you cannot
get better than two
and up to one point four fifty three is
the actual truth
and
montana showed that basically all the
way up to 1.53
uh
that you can you can achieve so
basically for this particular problem
this regime
this doesn't exist
so this regime doesn't exist there is no
uh hard search regime we you can you can
efficiently
find uh you can efficiently find an
algorithm all the way up to the ground
uh uh all the way up to the to the tooth
but this doesn't mean that this regime
doesn't exist the fact that this had
computationally hard regime doesn't
exist doesn't mean that this
computationally how the
regime doesn't exist
and in fact
we believe it does so there is a number
of errors
and i wanted to fill out the
all the results and i know there are
also some i think some recent ones that
maybe haven't yet come out and
um so
some there's definitely some several
works
pasta did you ever work on that and mark
did you ever work on that like
okay so
okay the
that works
showing giving evidence that this
two
is potentially the true
threshold so there is some partial
evidence that saying maybe this is
really the true uh threshold
computational threshold
so basically right now the what we
believe is that this regime doesn't
exist but this does exist
so basically it is how to it is how to
certify
and similar in similarly with planted it
will be hard to recover a planted signal
here even though uh
alex you must have worked on that right
yes
with whom
uh
okay yes
that's what you like to tag in
so so so there are there is evidence and
you would say that's that's a good
conjecture right that there is evidence
that this part that this would be hard
both for planted and for a refutation
right
uh i'm not sure even by planting but for
refuge yes computation and and i guess
there might be it should be a way to
plant a signal in the uh
like plant a boolean spike so that it
would be hard to recover like a 1.6 or
1.7 all right there is a higher there's
a way to plant it so that it's hard all
the way up yes but it's sort of a
special way yeah you have to be all of
these ways when you plant you have to
plant intelligently but but there is a
way to plant it so that
so basically refutation and planting
would be hard
uh so so basically the fact that they
so the fact that this regime
so so having this power this regime
doesn't the fact that this doesn't exist
doesn't mean that this part doesn't
exist and this can sometimes be
confusing so
if you're like a physicist and you just
look at
at this part you could say ah this
problem is computationally solved
you know if you're just interested in
inference for example recovering the
signal then you might say okay this this
part this left part doesn't interest me
because this is basically what you've
said that you can recover the noise
so basically this is uh
so so these kind of motivates are
looking at refutation problems so the
refutation problem is to certify that
the minimum is at least some beta
and you could care like why you know
refutation
generally is not the most natural
problem so you could say why do you even
care about refutation
uh after all you know
proving things is something that somehow
only mathematicians care about and
everyone knows that mathematicians are
not important right
i mean
otherwise why do we need to you know
everyone i mean we know we are not
important also right uh that's why
we're just trying i mean between
ourselves we know that we're not
important we just don't tell it to them
[Laughter]
this is
this is taken from my
slides deck for my startup that's i
guess i guess maybe that's the reason
why i never got funded
so
so so basically one one reason to care
about refutation uh aside from every
approving things
is that and
that if you show that refutation is hard
maybe you're showing the refutation is
easy it's not clear what it's
interesting for but if you show that
it's hard then it also implies the
decision is how the hypothesis testing
is something natural
and the other thing is really that
refutation threshold it tends to
basically is the same pressure that's
the planted recovery or the inference
problem at least if you uh for the
harder version of the plant today if you
plant properly
and and inference is really the part
that we do care about
so so we really do have this intuition
that basically uh this refutation phase
is basically when the recovery becomes
computationally easy versus
computationally hard
and the intuition is that
we think of our data as signal plus
noise
and when we when we are able to refute
the noise when we are able to say that
the noise couldn't have contributed to
the objective then we could recover the
the signal
and and and here is kind of like how do
we do this planting so
generally planting can be complicated
but like in the p-spin things it's
fairly simple
you want to generate
some j-star to ensure that the minimum
is
is this planted signal x-star
so for 3xo the most natural thing to do
is you just generate constraints that
are consistent with this x star so
you're saying you know you rather than
either plus or minus
a random j would either be either plus
or minus here it's a you know it's
either zero when there is no constraint
or plus or minus here would you say it's
always going to be the thing that
ensures that x star is the minimizer
so this is kind of the noiseless version
to apply it and you can also have like a
noisy version
and
to ensure that gaussian elimination
doesn't work and so where you add a
little bit of noise but this noise can
be really small
to already kill gaussian elimination
and there is the spike tensor model
where you think of say
gaussian coefficients
and and you just take a random you know
j prime to be like say random normals
and then you add
lambda times x
times your signal so this lambda here is
very natural to think about it as the
signal-to-noise ratio
and you can really also think of a
delta the number of constraints you
expose is also the signal-to-noise ratio
or say the number of samples you observe
if you're doing inference so this is
basically the
sparse parity flip space party with
noise problem right
this version
and the and basically the delta is like
the number of samples we observed
and and generally this is my intuition
which i think i hope that eventually
will they have more formal way but my
intuition is that kind of the way to
merge this system these two views
is that there is some quantity that's
kind of like the refutation entropy
some upper bound of this red curve
which is kind of the feasible
the the
the computationally certifiable upper
bound of this red curve
there is some regime which i don't know
exactly how long it lasts
where this is tight
and then at some point uh
you cannot certify
a tight upper bound
up until the refutation threshold where
you can certify it and then basically
this is the point where things become
easy
so that's kind of my intuition but i
don't think yes yet we have works to uh
to show that and and
but the thing the the
maybe the most powerful refutation type
of algorithm that we have
is this sum of squares algorithm
now i'm sure a pavilion
and and i'll just kind of do a slide i
will think we'll see more maybe in
pasad's talk about sum of squares but
i'm gonna just do a slide on sum of
squares
so we want to certify that the minimum
is at least better how do you do that
here is a way to do that
so j is just a polynomial so you write
j as beta plus another polynomial that
is a sum of squares what does it mean a
sum of squares
sum of squares polynomial that is a sum
of squares it can never be negative
so this really certifies that j is
always at least better and if you're
working
and if you're only interested in xa in
the boolean cube
then
you don't need this j to be
equal
to beta plus s os x everywhere it's
enough for it to be equal
only on the boolean cube which means
basically you can say this is this is
equality of polynomials
but you mod out
by
any polynomial that is a multiple of a
of something that vanishes on the say
the boolean cube so if it was the
boolean q plus minus one then this
polynomial vanishes on it x i squared
minus one if you're working on the
sphere then this is the polynomial that
vanishes on it so basically you uh you
only need the certificate to show that
you you're equal over the domain you're
interested in
and the complexity of the sum of squares
proof
is the degree of this sos polynomial
and then generally if you look at the
set of all polynomials of degree at most
d and n variables
that uh our sum of squares
then a convex comma a convex combination
of a sum of squares
is a convex is also a sum of squares so
this is a convex subset of r n to the d
the roughly n to the d coefficients
maybe a little bit more who cares
something like that
and it has a separation oracle because
this is basically like
checking eigenvalues is it is like you
can embed those as positive
semi-dimensional matrices
so you can optimize over that
so using a semi-definite programming you
can optimize that in time and to the ofd
so that's
so degree captures the time complexity
to optimize
and when you have this
when whenever you have like a convex
optimization you also have duality
so the dual object for this certificate
would be a linear operator that takes a
polynomial and outputs a number
and we call it this degree d pseudo
expectation operator and though
the
conditions we want from it is that e of
one equals one and again if it was an
expectation the expectation of one
should be one
if a polynomial p p is in the ideal it
vanishes over the domain then e of p
times q should be it should be zero so
in some sense uh
you know if it's supposed to vanish it
should vanish
and and
e of p squared should be non-negative
expectation of a squared should be
non-negative so it satisfies
the conditions of an expectation but
it's only defined up to degree d
and
and for natural s
such as like the sphere of the cube up
to some accuracy basically degree a
constant times n so the expectation
means that it's an actual expectation
and there is kind of an easy claim to
show that the the side of one side of
this duality is that
if there is such a pseudo expectation
and it satisfies that expectation of j
is less than b then you're never going
to certify using the degree d
sum of squares certificate
that uh
you're never going to certify that
you know so even if they're you know
maybe the minimum is really larger than
better
but if there is an er and suddenly the
expectation that pretends that the
minimum is smaller than better you're
not going to have the greedy certificate
and and the the the proof is kind of
immediately immediately so you know if
you
if you take the expectation of this
certificate
then
this condition implies that this part is
negative
and expectation of better is just better
so uh
so if there was a certificate then for
every degree to the expectation it will
have to be the case that the expectation
of j is at least better
and that in particular means that if d
is roughly n
then uh
then the certificate is actually the the
the on you can only certify it if it's
true
and
you can
if it's really true that the minimum of
j of x is at least better you can
certify it because and
because the in this case there is an
actual expectation if and only if
the minimum is um
if and only if the minimum is in
is at least better
okay so
okay maybe
because i think we're running out of
time i'll not talk about pseudo
calibration
and kind of jump to a
the
high level
point so basically for pxos for example
we have a refutation uh threshold
that is about
when we have so we have about n
constraints say roughly and if it's
noise
then uh there is no no longer uh the the
random consensus function
is no longer
there is no longer a random solution so
if you are the planted solution the
planted solution is only the one that
remained
so information theoretically it's
possible to solve the say p parity with
noise problem at a roughly and samples
but we need something like n to the p
over two samples to actually show uh
solve it
effectively
and
while we
my my dream picture of uh refutation
entropy we don't know exactly how to do
it but if at least in this kind of
regime ignore this part which is very
speculative at least in this part of
regime
if instead of thinking of as an entropy
you'd think of it as the log of the one
time to refute then there is such a
curve like that that flil and pasadena
numbers of uh
environmentalists kind of shown
that there is evidence that we have this
kind of smooth curve where you can
refute here but it's not in polynomial
time it will be kind of sub-exponential
time
and
and yeah and and
sos is not the only kind of algorithm
for say inference and planting but it
has some advantages it's
can simulate many of these other
algorithms and it's very general in some
sense the sos program writes itself
it doesn't analyze itself right now but
at least
it's kind of obvious what the program is
for at least for refutation and so and
you don't need creativity and like we
said we want to automate creativity you
don't need a creativity in the algorithm
design
and
maybe the most important thing is that
it extends
all of this talk was about random
problems but in real life we also care a
lot about this kind of robust setting or
adversarial setting where
maybe then
we have some random input but some of
them like we also have maybe arbitrary
errors and sos kind of naturally extend
to this thing
and the main disadvantage is that
although sos is polynomial time it's not
really efficient in practice but there's
been a lot of work but still some and
many others on making a transforming sos
algorithms into
efficient
and did i completely run out of time
i mean i'm personally happy for you to
continue all evening
i mean but no truly so um
yeah
so i mean i'm happy for everyone to
leave if they need to i can just say
maybe
i can take maybe
three more minutes to say
the difference between
like to talk a little bit about modern
machine learning versus these kind of
notions of imprints and
something a little bit more speculative
so
so basically what's like
i mean inference is
the focus of this workshop and focus
what we're doing but what's the
difference between that and what people
do in modern machine learning is where
they solve non-convex uh optimization
and let me say what i
see as different i'm not sure if that's
universally agreed the way i see it is
in inference problems you have data
and you invent some generative model
that you believe that generated this
data so in adam clivenstock the
generative model maybe was you know rbm
or
easing model or whatever and and then
you want to recover the parameters
of that model
and in practice why do you want to
recover the parameters to do
so you do run some optimization let's
say you're trying to maximize the
probability and why do you want to
recover the parameters you're going to
do
some tasks with these parameters but
that's kind of outside the model you
first recover the parameters once you do
that you kind of understood the data and
you could do a lot of things it
any kind of model in modern machine
learning we
we get data we don't want to talk about
a generative model we don't know
and we want an algorithm that will give
us parameters but not really parameters
from the data but parameters to
whatever we are going to do the task
with
and our
optimization will be the success of the
task so we don't have a generative model
of the data we just want to
find
something that will help us do the task
and the difference between x and theta
is account
like typically in in inference the theta
is very clean
fixed model for data and here we have a
lot of freedom
of what to choose x as
and the key differences maybe if you
compare this machine learning view with
inference
is the following so on one hand the
loss function in here even here it's
kind of often will be non-convex and
very complicated but at least it's kind
of clean and analyzable or at least you
can write it as in math
here the loss function
and especially once you start to do like
the you know loss functions that are
used for self-supervised learning or for
i don't know reinforcement learning or
whatever they could be very very
complicated loss function so that in
principle makes
seems to make the problem
computationally harder but the key thing
that we have that could make the problem
computationally easier is that we have
complete freedom of the choice of
representation
and we uh generally will look at much
more data potentially than what we could
we would have needed in the minimal case
and the freedom in the loss of
representation is in the choice of
representation is actually often
important in terms of making the problem
easy
for example if we talk about supervised
learning
often it's the case that's a
the the
number of parameters you have is so big
that if someone asks you just use those
parameters to build the lookup table to
implement a lookup table so that it will
fit the train data
perfectly it would be very simple
computationally to do
so this is not sometimes people say wow
it's amazing that in machine learning
you solve np hard problems
it's actually very trivial to solve the
training problem what is surprising is
that you solve the training problem and
it actually works
beyond training but the the
computational the fact that you find in
a minimum for the training is not very
surprising
because basically what uh you know it
amounts to i say
you know if i if i gave you a
a list of ten thousand uh
pairs and i and and i gave you you know
enough freedom that you could just write
a lookup table uh you can encode the
lookup table in this new network it's
not how to do
so
but the key similarity between inference
and this machine learning is that you
still use even in ml et cetera you end
up using gradient descent you use the
same local algorithms so something here
is similar
and empirically there is this thing that
basically you are doing this sequence of
local steps local improvements
and and there it seems to be this thing
that basically as long as
you somehow didn't saturate performance
you didn't run out of
fuel
you can find some local improvement
such that two things happen first of all
it performs better on the observed data
so you can run gradient descent
and keep optimizing on your training
data you can find some
modifications say gradient step et
cetera that
improves your performance on the
training set
and also empirically
these two each one of those steps not
just at the very end but each one of
those steps
will improve your performance even on
unseen data until you run out of fuel
and the way you want to make sure that
you don't run out of fuel
that you saturate later is you generally
use more data and bigger models
so the bigger your models the the more
your data generally kind of delays the
point of time and which one of those
things stops to be true
so at some point you know if your model
is too small at some point you're not
going to be able to continue to do
better and observe data and if your data
is not enough then at some point you're
not going to you you stop doing better
on unseen data but
the more you have of these resources the
better you are and i just wanted to kind
of add like this uh show this
slide of this deep food stuff that we
walk off
nakivan as my student and
bishop and sergey that had these nice
ways where they tracked
what happens
in the real world where you
doing training you you take steps on a
fixed set of data
and what would have happened in an ideal
world where you had infinitely amount of
fresh data and basically they showed
that at least until you saturate these
things track each other very well like
where how you uh
every step you do you you
whether it's with limited data with
infinite data it kind of improves
it it kind of improves um
in a similar way and i don't have time
to explain this more but i'm happy to
talk about it later so let me
just finish with this
last say that basically we what we've
seen in and i think this how this
semester will help put this picture in
more
is that you know we we have
a collection of natural algorithms and
they all seem to face barriers in more
or less the same locations
and i think we have seen the evidence
that this is really inherent
but there is still more work to do and
in particular i think the the thing that
bothers me is that basically
we still have uh need to write a new
paper every time we consider a new
problem or a new algorithm
where uh
and also this difference
there are these two different regimes
that we i really hope we will be able to
unify them eventually and so
and and the hope is that eventually we
will get the case to the case where you
describe a problem
like uh by say an average case problem
using a generative model
and immediately uh you could write you
know you could run it for computer
program that will tell you here is where
all the thresholds will be and here is
the what the optimal algorithm will do
in all of the regimes
and
with that just very sorry for taking
more of your time and and
that's it thank you
[Applause]
so it probably is time for maybe a
couple of quick questions and then we
have a reception at which you can
continue to ask voice more questions
so is there a can you make a more formal
or generic connection between reputation
and they're planted in solving the
planted search
and you you've alluded many times to the
exact same problem but is there some
reduction there or so so i think maybe
some of these proof to uh
so so so there's definitely i think
certain strengths in which you have this
uh
proof to uh
algorithm
type of framework where at least
if you can refute you can recover
and that i think is
is somewhat generical formal would you
say that someone
[Music]
i think i think i think with enough
assumptions on what kind of model you're
in you know these
these generic these these simple toy
models have some kind of signal plus
noise structure in the planted settings
and i think with enough assumptions on
how signal and noise go together you can
probably show
uh yeah something like you know refuting
being able to up
you know refuting recovering and
optimizing are all going to be corners
of some triangle and they probably are
like definitely optimizing is good
enough for
refusing anyway we could talk about it
offline
but then i mean
proper reductions reductions i actually
don't think so unless there's like a lot
of assumptions
but
maybe
for particular kinds of algorithms you
could say well if this kind of algorithm
does this then this kind of algorithm
can do this too i'm not exactly sure
but the kind of general idea of like
proof to uh recovery is kind of a case
where you
you look at an identifiability proof
which often is
in its heart
also implies a reputation of the random
part
and and that
and that identifiability proof is then
sometimes you can kind of almost
automatically translate it into an a
recovery algorithm but
i think it's then
yeah not as formal as we would like or
gentlemen
yes
um so in the start of your health you
mentioned that there's actually very few
algorithmic programs that we applied to
what's the problem
just kind of curiosity does
algorithm follow
yes basically
which are basically local uh
[Applause]
just outside